[Music]  would you like to have more children  absolutely I hope I hope I have what  children in the basket is told us she  definitely wants more kids to add to six  and a half year old Bing who she shares  with Matt Bellamy and 14 year old writer  her son with Chris Robinson when I was  pregnant with Ryder I just started to  bake we were with Kate inside her home  last November where she told us about  her chemistry with boyfriend of 16  months musician and first-time dad to be  Danny Fujikawa sex is an important part  of relationships you have to nurture  that people go like I wasn't that cheesy  like taking a bath together like having  champagne like no because one of two  things is gonna happen you're gonna set  up the romantic vibe and you're either  gonna laugh your ass off or you're gonna  have like or you're gonna commit to it  and it's gonna be awesome  [Music]  [Applause]